a Las Vegas woman dies after friends and
family say she was shot by her boyfriend
eight news now reporter Victoria Saha
joins us from UMC she spoke with the
person who was there when 26 year old
Tabitha tozzi was injured
top of the toesi was well known in the
Las Vegas nightlife scene but now the 26
year old is the center of a difference
scene here at UMC as her organs are
being donated friends and family are
remembering her Legacy of giving back I
can't imagine like living and going on
without her they were best friends but
more like sisters if you met her you saw
light light that's now gone for those
who loved Tabitha toesie she got me out
of my shell she showed me how to use my
voice Josie's best friend doesn't want
us to share her identity as she's still
coming to terms with the tragedy she was
never the type of person to get violent
or physical or let anyone be physical
towards her so I know like he there was
no domestic violence issue in the
relationship at all her best friend says
they were returning from a night out
Saturday morning when a fight between
tozi and her boyfriend escalated she was
trying to leave with her car and he
wouldn't let her the best friend tells
us moments later tozi's boyfriend
approached her car this time without
tozy telling her she needs to get out
I'm getting out because he has a gun in
his hand fearing the worst she runs to
her best friend finding her shot in the
head she was still gasping she she was
still fighting she still fought she
fought here tozi's fight at the hospital
ended Monday night now those who loved
her are trying to figure out what life
looks like without her this is a
guardian angel in real life bro like the
real life Guardian Angel to everyone
now toesie most recently worked along
Fremont Street they say Tabitha was an
integral part of the team will never be
forgotten and Metro Police have not
released a name of the person of
interest which is why we've not
identified the boyfriend's name